hello friends my name is sahil and this
is my personal finance academy
there are 6 000 companies listed on nse
for any investor
the biggest task is to identify the top
companies from this huge ocean of stock
market
especially for new investors it is very
difficult to identify quality stocks
some of them end up investing in penny
stock or very small companies
without solid management and financial
and
they eventually lose money in the stock
market hence
over the past few weeks i have curated a
list of top 18 large cap stock
top 10 mid cap stock and top 10 small
cap stock
with great management great business
great financial
and solid growth respect but there are
still a lot of great companies that i
could not include in my list
i have been doing a lot of research and
number crunching and i have identified
hundred plus super stock
across various sector in india these
stocks are gem of gems
my selection criteria is based on
analysis of company
and its business competitive strength
financials
and future growth respect please note
that this list
only covers stock with market cap more
than thousand crore
so i have not included micro cap stocks
there are mainly two reason
first is they are highly volatile
company that can be driven by operators
and second there is little information
available about them on public domain
currently there are about 750 plus
companies with a market share of
thousand plus crore
out of those i've identified 100 plus
companies
i've categorized them into various
sectors so we will pick the companies
sector by sector and folks before we
start with the list
i am not sure if you are aware but i am
an ex-data analytics consultant
and i love doing number crunching i have
created
a light record of all these companies
with all the relevant information
required for quickly analyzing the
company i will share the details
at the end of this video please note
that this video is for
educational purpose and this list is
only for the short listing
you should do an in-depth research
including the valuation analysis before
investing
your money all right i have divided this
video in two parts
in the first part i've explained why you
should invest in indian economy
and then in second part i have mentioned
these stock names from each sector
so let's get started
before you even consider investing in
the indian stock market
you should know why it is worth
investing in the market
first reason is that it is the fastest
growing economy
folks india is one of the fastest
growing economy in the world
after the recent contraction in the
economy due to covet
imf that is the international monetary
fund has forecasted a growth rate
of 11.5 percent in fi 22.
as per the latest news india is
currently ranked sixth
in terms of gdp however india is
expected to become
the third largest economy by 2030
overtaking japan germany and the uk
second reason is that india is one of
the biggest consumer market
the sheer size of indian population
which is the second largest in the world
makes india one of the biggest consumer
market of the world
no wonder why companies like amazon to
google to facebook to tesla
are keen on investing in indian market
next reason is rising income and
spending level
friends as the economy is growing the
salary levels are rising
today we have more working population
including women
the rising income level is resulting in
a need for a better lifestyle
and increasing spending level next
reason is
youngest country we are one of the
youngest nations in the world
with a median age of 29 year this young
workforce
creates immense potential for growth
next reason is
low cost workforce one of the biggest
advantage of india's economy
is the low-cost workforce as compared to
the developed nations
like the us or the japan this is one of
the reason
why india is the i.t hub of the world
and also
a preferred nation for r d activities
especially in the pharma sector
this also creates a huge opportunity in
the manufacturing segment
next reason is adoption of technology
earlier known as the land of snake
charmers
india has now become the i.t hub of the
world what a brilliant transformation
21st century is all about digital and we
are one of the front runner
in this digital transformation for
example the upi payment is a classic
case
of india's digital transformation in
banking space
where we can transfer money from one
account to another within few seconds
today even the remotest villages have
good internet connection
likewise we have significantly
progressed in areas like
e-commerce online education or advanced
technologies
india is transforming at a very fast
rate indian government
is focused towards the digital movement
with digital india initiative
which would be the key to india's
dominance in the 21st century
friends i am not saying that india is a
perfect country
there are many flaws however if you look
at the last 20 years
we have come a long way i strongly
believe that the way u.s has grown in
the last 20 years
or china has grown in the last 25 years
india would grow similarly
for the next 30 to 50 years and the 21st
century would belong to india
having said this a lot would depend upon
execution
but i am a strong believer in india's
growth journey and i think that
it is the best opportunity to invest in
india now let's start with our list of
top stock
in each sector
first sector is fmcg in food which is an
evergreen sector
no matter we would continue to consume
the food and daily essential item
this sector also enjoys very high
profitability
as the debtors day are very low in fmcg
my topics include hul itc nestle
dabur britannia goldridge consumer tata
consumer product
and maricopa in food category i have
jubilant food work
varun beverage avanti feed hindustan
food
and testy bites banking and financial
services are the backbone of the economy
an economy can't grow without the
support of banking sector
within banking and financial services
let's start with private banks
my top lists include sdfc bank icca bank
kotek bank excess bank bandhan bank and
idfc first bank
in public banks i have sbi bank and bank
of baruda
in small finance category i have au
small finance
within financial services i have sdfc
limited
bajaj print serve and max financial
within nbfc
my list include bajaj finance mutual
finance and manapuram finance
friends there is an ever growing demand
for healthcare sector
due to rising lifestyle diseases and
various other factors
especially after covet we have realized
the importance of healthcare even more
within healthcare let's first start with
pharma my list include
sun pharma divislab sipla aurobindo
pharma
dr reddy abort ipka lab laura's lab
olympic pharma land pharma and sequence
science
within diagnostic it include dr lal
patlab
metropolis healthcare and thyrocare
this is the hottest sector currently in
india due to structural shift
from china to india and i have many
companies in this category
my list include pedilite ati industry
deepak nitrite venati organics tata
chemical naveen fluorine
alkynamine balaji amine galaxy
surfactant
atul limited fine organics chemcom
specialty
and advanced enzyme within agrochemical
i have pi industry bare crop science
coromandel international
dhanuka agrotech sumitomo chemical and
bharathrasayan
again a key sector with immense growth
potential due to the next wave of growth
in
electrical vehicle in four wheeler
passenger and commercial vehicle
i have tata motor maruti suzuki m m that
is mahindra and mahindra
ashokley lane within two wheeler i have
hiro motor car
aisha motor bajaj auto and tvs
within auto auxiliary my list include
madasan sumi
honeywell auto endurance technology
excite battery
amra raja battery webco india mrf
and bulk krishna industry
friends the future is digital and itn
technology
sector has image growth potential within
it
my list include tcs infosys wipro
hcl tech mahindra lnt infotech
free persistent system and happiest mind
within software and technology category
my list include
tata lxe scient sonata software
info edge lnt technology india mart
intermesh
3m india go forge tella platform
apple india route mobile cams and iex
electrical and electronics are again a
basic necessity
my list include havels india whirlpool
of india
chromtem greaves polycap ttk prestige
phenolics cable ki industries hawking
cookers
and orient electric
friends infrastructure is one segment
that would see tremendous growth
due to construction of roads buildings
airports
ports etc within infra let's start with
cement
my list include ultra tech cement sri
cement ambuja cement
and jk cement within construction i have
lnt within ceramics it includes kajarya
ceramic
and serra sanitary wear within paint it
includes asian paint
burger paint cansan and leg and indigo
paints
in power and steel it include tata power
and tata steel
within plastic and piping my list
include astral poly technique
supreme industry phenolics industry and
prince pipes
next sector is textile textiles include
page industry trident lux industries and
gearware technical
next sector is amc it includes sdfc amc
uti amc and nippon amc
next sector is insurance which include
sdfc life
sbi life icse prudential life next
sector is
retail which include titan avenue
supermarket
and trent next sector is manufacturing
which include dixon technology amber
enterprise
gmm foddler and voltas next sector is
utility
which include interest gas mahanagar gas
and gujarat gas
next is telecom which includes reliance
and airtel
friends reliance is a cognitive but i
have kept it in telecom category
now let's look at the miscellaneous
category it include
irctc from catering and tourism weber
global from jewelry
relax of footwear and bata from footwear
sector crystal from research
sheila form from firm and mattress
century plywood from ply sector
and finally it includes united breweries
united spirit
and radical kittan from brewery and
distillery sector
so this is my list of top companies in
indian stock market
did i miss any great company with a
market cap of more than thousand crore
let me know in the comment box and as i
mentioned in my previous video the
markets are
in an overvalued state so invest
sensibly
but this list could be a great starting
point for you to pick stock for the
universe of indian stock market i might
have missed a few stock here and there
but this list more or less covers the
gems of gems
having said this the stock market is
dynamic so i will keep reviewing this
list periodically
and add or remove stocks as per
situation
folks you can access this list on my
website for free
this list include information like
company name sector
current market cap current market price
valuation
52 week high 52 week low percentage
below 52 week high
and percentage above 52-week low
yesterday closing price
and percentage change in share price
from yesterday
it also include 5-year profit growth and
5-year roce
in addition i have also updated the
sheet with top 18 large cap
top 10 mid cap and top 10 small cap
in the future i will curate more list
based on various themes like technology
health care etc
and based on various risk profiles and
other factors
to learn more about money management you
can explore my video course which covers
everything
including stock mutual fund insurance
text planning etc
i am sure you will find it very helpful
till then
take care